.
BUT THE CONGRESSMAN IS TOTALLY
INTIMIDATED, WHICH IS WHY WE'RE
GRATEFUL HE JOINS US NOW.
HE REPRESENTS THE STATE OF
LOUISIANA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
I MEAN, I'M JUST WONDERING WHAT
WAS GOING THROUGH YOUR MIND.
YOU ASKED THE BASIC QUESTION.
HOW IS SOCIETY GOING TO MENTION
WITHOUT PETROCHEMICALS?
DID YOU EXPECT SOME ANSWER?
>> I KNEW THAT HER POSITION WAS
INSANE.
MS. SALTERS, A RADICAL CLIMATE
ATTORNEY, LIKELY A FRIEND OF
AOC'S, IN A WEEK WHERE WE HAD TO
ENDURE COMMITTEE HEARING AFTER
COMMITTEE HEARING WERE THE
DEMOCRATS WERE SMASHING THE
AMERICAN ENERGY INDUSTRY AND
PROMOTING THE ABSUFFEREDDITIES
OF THE FURTHEST REACHES OF THE
GREEN NEW DEAL.
THEIR STAR WITNESS, AFTER TWO
DAYS OF HEARINGS, ON THE SECOND
PANEL, THE SECOND DAY, WAS THIS
LADY, MS. SALTERS.
I HAD POSSESSION OF HER WRITTEN
TESTIMONY.
I HAD READ IT.
I WAS PREPARED.
I KNEW HOW CRAZY IT READ.
WHEN SHE DELIVERED IT IN HER
OPENING STATEMENT, SHE WAS QUITE
VITRIOL LICK, PRACTICALLY
SPITTING AT US.
HER ANGER WAS JUST UNBELIEVABLE.
SO I KNEW WHEN I HAD A CHANCE
TO, I WAS GOING TO SHUT HER DOWN
WITH HER OWN CRAZINESS.
>> Tucker: BOY, YOU DID SUCH A